so when it comes to Avengers for leaks
we love them we'll take anything that we
can get because truthfully we don't
really know too much about Avengers 4
and the Russo brothers and Marvel are
keeping us as much in the dark as they
possibly can including not giving us a
title or a trailer so leaks are the only
thing that we can really cling on to
right now and a couple of weeks ago we
got a leak that showed us the back of a
toy packaging that had Thor and rocket
on it now on the back of this packaging
there was also a description and in the
description it said that the Avengers
would have to face off against a greater
threat so it seems like the people were
kind of divided on what this meant a lot
of people thought that it meant there is
a new greater villain coming van Phan
owes a greater threat than Thanos but
some also said that this does not
necessarily mean that the greater threat
is somebody different than Thanos it
could simply be that owes but a new
threat that he presents to them but we
now have clarification we know exactly
what this toy leak was talking about now
and it's all thanks to the book Avengers
infinity war at the cosmic quest volume
2 aftermath just so everybody is aware
the events that take place in this book
are in the MCU it's sort of like the
prelude comics how it shows you what
happened and it shows a little bit of
the behind the scenes that we didn't see
but it still took place in the MCU this
book is the same way and what this book
is about is the events that take place
after the snap specifically about dr.
Erik Selvig and Darcy and I'll just read
to you what the back of the book says it
says a deadly threat emerged from the
cosmos and it was fulfilled in the wake
of Thanos horrifying success the people
of Earth are left reeling in despair and
confusion without any logical
explanation for the bleep out event
those remaining must pick up the pieces
dr. Erik Selvig and his associate Darcy
Lewis are determined to find out and
understand the cause of the devastation
with a team of friends both old and new
they embark on a pursuit of knowledge
eager to discover the links between
their own pasts and the stones that
decimated half of humanity the Infinity
stones
do they know that a new foe who
threatens to destroy them all is looming
so as you just heard a new foe is coming
and it mentions Thanos in the same
description so it's saying that there is
a new foe that is not Thanos that is
coming it actually says looming and to
me this kind of implies that there's a
villain out there that has wanted to
attack earth for a really long time but
hasn't because of the heroes on it but
thanks to Thanos a snap half of them are
gone so this new villain that is out
there could see this as the perfect time
to strike earth it could be the scroll
because we know they're going to be in
Captain Marvel and the scrollview
earth as there's but the most popular
theory right now is that it's Annihilus
and this stems from the wide belief that
Avengers 4 is actually going to be
titled Avengers annihilation Annihilus
could be hiding in the negative zone
which they could easily make the quantum
realm in Avengers 4 not to mention the
release of this book and his description
confirm that the toy League was real and
with that toy leaked Thor and Rocket
were wearing what appeared to be quantum
realm suits so you link the new suits
with the new foe and it appears that
this new foe will somehow be in the
quantum realm but whoever it is this
book description confirms that there is
going to be a new separate villain than
Thanos in Avengers 4 so who do you all
think and hope that this new villain is
going to be in Avengers 4 let me know
your thoughts in the comments below
don't forget about the giveaway I'm
doing if you'd like to enter for your
chance to win a copy of infinity war the
art of the movie art book a copy of
infinity war Deadpool 2 or ant-man and
the wasp on blu-ray as well as some
special edition posters all you have to
do is subscribe to my channel like the
video and comment down below with your
thoughts and your favorite superhero as
always thank you all so much for
watching Wolf Wolf
[Music]